uh for me popularity contests
are not a good way to measure the worth
of anything
i think we need to think more deeply
more critically to find out whether
something is good or bad
a valuable or worthless worth doing or
not worth doing but there's a big
contingent that supports donald trump
uh as well as to donald trump personally
to whom everything is popularity it's
approval rating
it's the size of trump's crowd it's that
type of thing
and along these lines is a very
triggering poll
for donald trump which has already been
released and it shows that
joe biden is already weeks before taking
office
more popular than donald trump has ever
been during his entire presidency the
numbers are really
stunning gallup has been tracking
presidential approval
for decades both during transition
periods
and presidencies and joe biden's
approval has risen to 55 percent
already and this is a number that trump
has never reached
during his entire presidency trump never
got to 50
and is currently dipped down to 42
percent approval
while joe biden has jumped to 55 and
something
very interesting are the sort of
internals of these numbers how they're
made up
in terms of party where we see that over
the month from mid-october to
mid-november
biden's approval among republicans
doubled
the numbers are still low but it doubled
from 6 to 12.
biden's approval among independents is
up 7 points 48 to 55
and it's basically unchanged changed
among democrats because it was already
at 95 percent it went to 96.
now donald trump's approval also hasn't
changed among democrats it's at three
percent
it was at three percent before and it's
at three percent now independent
approval of trump is almost unchanged
down two points
but trump among republicans has lost six
points
of approval so there's a few important
aspects to the story
number one trump has been and remains a
historically unpopular president trump
is the outlier here typically the
president-elect
gets a bump when they're awaiting
inauguration trump never got that back
in november of 2016
december of 2016 and and the first part
of january 2016.
and in the end that's not really
surprising because in 2016 remember that
donald trump
won electorally with the biggest
popular vote loss of anything we've seen
for a winning president
but there's actually more to this the
reason i care about this is not just
trump will be triggered okay what we
have right now
is a situation where we will be changing
federal leadership
in the middle of the absolute worst
moment in the united states of a global
hundred year pandemic
the importance of joe biden building
goodwill with as
many people in the united states as
possible can't possibly be overstated
and if biden's approval has already
jumped to 55
presumably at least some of it because
joe biden formed a coronavirus task
force
has actually provided some parallel
leadership to trump when it comes to the
virus
has announced he'll be bringing on
anthony fauci as chief medical advisor
hopefully people are seeing
the approach of biden and are reacting
to it with goodwill
because on day one joe biden is going to
have to spring into action now
of course unj biden will be inaugurated
january 20th
you know and i know that on january 21st
january 23rd maybe at the latest
republicans will start blaming biden for
coronavirus deaths even though
of course all of this has to do with the
federal failure to start testing and
deal with this seriously at the
beginning
uh cases and deaths reflect activity
weeks and months prior okay we already
know that
but on day one joe biden is going to
come in and he's going to say
let's listen to the science and medical
community um
and if we see joe biden spike to maybe
60
approval or 62 hopefully he will get as
much of the country as possible on board
with working together to deal with the
virus
that's the top priority right now
presidents come and go
tracking approval rating is not very
important in the abstract but right now
we've had as many as 230 000 coronavirus
cases in a day
we're starting to see days with 3 000
deaths
we are starting to see vaccines
hopefully rolling out this month
presidential approval actually right now
connects with saving lives in that it
will
signal buy-in with what incoming
president joe biden will likely be
asking people to do
including wearing masks when he's sworn
in and yes
the optics of highly triggerable
popularity obsessed trump already being
outdone by joe biden's approval before
biden is even president
i do admit that it's funny in a sense
but it also is very important